I'm Austin Eckler and have some fans
depending on me to deliver their
ubereats order
let's get it there before kickoff
[Music]
thought that the pizza was for me pizza
is not for me the pizza is actually for
our fan so not eating a slice of their
Pizza
[Music]
pressure is there but it's just like any
other pressure from the team it's all
part of the package my go-to Uber Eats
order there's a lot of good dumpling
places around my place and so I'm
usually picking up some type of dumpling
and like they're like special sauces and
stuff like that
so yeah we are currently stuck in a
construction zone so doing our best
don't want the food to get cold
all right so we are one minute out and
this looks like the final turn that
we're coming up on so we are about to
complete this order and I would say so
far it's gone pretty well we are showing
up on trash day so there's limited
parking here and it's kicked off so
that's you know we got to get there we
gotta find parking around all these
trash cans we made it officially here
let's go make somebody's day now do you
open the door or you take the food out
first I feel if I if I take I gotta open
the door because if you don't open the
door then you have no hands because
you're holding the food all right all
right now I gotta make it over this
steering wheel pants get caught on the
seat what is that now grab the food and
that's how you get out of the car ladies
and gentlemen
[Music]
who's here come on let's go yeah the
food's here hey what's going on
I'm here with your Uber Eats order yes
we got some hungry fans in here yes sir
how's it going well we got your food got
it on time thank you absolutely yeah get
your ball let's play some catch
all right
ah all right KJ good stuff man you enjoy
your food I'm out of here we'll see you
guys
see ya
[Music]